huit mille personnes incluant les
enfants c'est toute la petite ville de
telluride au colorado qui est testé
depuis quelques jours pour le corps
navires us l'objectif identifier les
citoyens qui ont déjà été contaminées
par la coved 19
le test est réalisé à partir d'une
goutte de sang et le résultat est connu
en une quinzaine de minutes
c'est ce qu'on appelle un test
sérologique une technologie éprouvée
pour un grand nombre de virus et qu'on
essaie maintenant d'adapter à la
nouvelle menace donc l'état sérieuses
sont très importants parce qu'on a
présentement au test que les gens qui
sont symptomatiques
donc on n'arrive pas testé toute la
population en général donc on doit
maintenant savoir quelle partie la
population étaient exposés aux corvées
19 et qui est immunisée contre la coved
19 ans ladies and équipe dans le non
dont celle de jean françois masson
tentent actuellement d'identifier quels
anticorps de notre organisme réagissent
le plus fortement la présence du virus
plus la réaction sera forte et plus le
test sera précis indicateurs donc s'ils
ont été exposés au virus
ils vont rester un certain temps dans
notre organisme dans notre corps et dont
on parle est détectée mais après qu'on
ait combattu le virus ce genre de test
va servir à identifier rapidement les
personnes immunisées dans certaines
catégories de travailleurs à risque
médecin personnel de la santé préposé
aux bénéficiaires policiers par exemple
puis on pourra définir le taux de
pénétration du virus dans la population
en général on empressement a besoin
d'être c'est toute la population mais si
on sait que par exemple nous avons eu 30
% l'infection 99 mais les scénarios vont
être mis en place pour répondre
pourcentage des gens qui ont un effet
développé un test fiable va changer la
donne dit le chercheur
et ce n'est qu'une question de temps
nous devrions voir dans les prochaines
semaines près tout prochains mois tout
au plus tard les premiers tests
homologué disponibles sur le marché
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal